si no se consigue consenso y lo cual
quiere decir que el proceso electoral
sigue su curso es regular el consejo
nacional electoral no ha conseguido los
votos suficientes para poder aprobar el
informe técnico y se evidencia que hay
diferencias entre los consejeros
electorales algunos se aprobaban para
continuar con el escrutinio de los votos
otros los consejeros también pedían el
rechazo del informe presentado que debía
abrir las urnas las provincias que tú
has mencionado y otros pedían también
reclamaban que esto generaría el rechazo
en el calendario electoral e inclusive
en la proclamación de los resultados y
la toma de posición
prevista para el 24 de mayo que va a
pasar bueno el proceso electoral debe
continuar de la forma regular se espera
que el 24 de febrero se proclamen los
resultados definitivos posteriormente la
programación los candidatos ya q pérez y
guillermo lasso podrían presentar
diferentes impugnaciones que consideren
al lugar pero los consejeros en algunos
casos consideran que no ha habido un
fraude electoral como lo sostiene ya q
pérez es de igual forma
el día de hoy se espera una rueda de
prensa por parte del candidato ya q
pérez enlace del pachakuti por el cual
también desde la noche de ayer hay
protestas en las inmediaciones del
consejo nacional electoral y se ha
iniciado lo que han llamado una caminata
por la base para para concentrarse así
el consejo nacional electoral